breathing's from podcast Ville it's
Monday the 27th the month is always
almost over and you're still looking at
your resolutions go [ __ ] yourself over
go back to snorting coke you a lot
happier anyway we'll give the church is
brought to you by audit calm the best in
the industry when it comes to [ __ ]
supplements I'm getting old I take two
of those f alpha brains and an expresso
you ain't stopping me [ __ ] as a
matter of fact alpha brain is holding a
sweepstakes till you order any alpha
brain any size the powder the pills you
getting entered into a raffle with you
when you get the to day on experience
all right who's better than [ __ ] you
nobody so going on at that time right
now press in church that he is letting
you know what [ __ ] time it is alright
let's start this pocket but guess what's
happening Big John McCarthy not much
brothers good to see you good to see you
too [ __ ] Nashville mentor I'm hanging
out with white people drinking mint
juleps then all of a sudden you Lou you
move to Vegas which is good because you
saved on taxes yep for six months and
then you [ __ ] disappear at the
Nashville I disappear Tennessee is the
same as Nevada four times so it's a very
good place for taxes and my wife was
tired of the desert she did not like
because you know when you know you came
out to my little tiny place I had at the
beach we had the I had the the ocean in
my backyard as far as the channels there
and she wanted that so I kind of live on
a lake area out there and it's really
nice you like Tennessee I love it people
are so nice how far are you from
Nashville about two hours okay two hours
from that so you got out of that you
know I didn't want to be in this city
know I'm old man and it's time to I
don't need the the party life anymore I
don't need to have you know the
excitement I like just I do my
woodworking I do projects kind of showed
Lee a little bit of stuff that I can and
uh just enjoying life and your melatonin
it
I'm Bellator and it all over the place
you know there are there
they just been a great company for me
they treat me great I love what they're
doing for the fighters are given
fighters a definite option and guys for
the most part they're making really good
money there so you know fighters need
options they need the ability to can't
have just one it's you know it's it's
nice to think that in the perfect world
that if there was just one organization
that that one organization would always
treat all those fighters well well they
can't do that and I don't expect it so
they can you know they picked their ones
that make them the money and then the
other ones they kind of well this is
what you get so there has to be options
for fighters and that's one of the
things that Bellator it does it gives
fighters options it gives them the
ability to say you know what I think I'm
worth more than what you want to give me
and I'm gonna go see and then this
person gives it to them and they say I
told you I was worth more because this
is about two things if you're a fighter
it's about searching for titles if
you're if you're really good and it's
about making money
there's a reason why you do this and
some people are in that just searching
for the title and they'll take the less
money to search for that title and
there's people who say you know what I'm
in this as a businessman and I'm good at
fighting and I can make money at it and
I know I have a limited amount of time
and I'm gonna make as much money as I
can to set myself up for the future and
set my family up for the future
those are your two ways of doing it and
there's nothing wrong with either way
I'm all for it but if you don't have
options of other promotions for people
you only have the one if you only had
the UFC those fighters are gonna make
less money the big the top guy he's
gonna make money no matter what but the
guys underneath them know they're gonna
have problems making more because
there's nowhere for them to go so Beltre
is a great option you know it's we never
see you know for years we always heard
the expression if I can do it over oh
yeah if you could do it over if you
could do it over if you can give
somebody advice you know and I'm 56 I'd
be 57 I had looked at football you know
you looked at football now yeah you look
at the UFC you look at my man let's not
say UFC let's say
word MMA because you got the fight
league now the profile EPFL Bellator one
championship got yeah you got one you've
got so many different things going
you're an amateur fighter you're a
college football player you're a
comedian you're a plumber anything
nowadays you have to look at things with
a plan
yeah if you might manage it today and I
come to you and say I think I'm not um
16 and two as an amateur fighter I've
been to Mexico
I've won Buffalo I fought in [ __ ] you
know Hong Kong podunk Indiana you know I
don't know Scott Shelby yeah Scott
Shelby Resorts re and uh I was a guy
Scott Coker reached out and I think it's
time I think as a manager I sit you down
as a man like oh this is the plan it's a
three-year plan it's a three-year plan
you're getting in and out in three years
Wow three years that's short but that's
good but if you think about what we've
seen yeah in the last 15 years as an MMA
fan as a NFL fan what's this lifespan
what's the career span of an NFL running
back we're on three okay you got three
or four years to prove yourself but for
a 22 year old grew up in the ghetto
eight [ __ ] twigs all his life his
father beat his mother raped him he's
coming behind you and I'm saying no it's
true okay so it's the same with iiiiii
I'm not following the sport as much as I
used to anymore I got a family I got you
know most of the exciting fights fight
on some reason land on nights that
you're you're out doing your job I don't
like the whole I want to turn it on
Spike I want to turn it on Spike
let's take a but that's Bellator because
that's what we're on once I got a spec
the road
and it is getting more difficult isn't
it I got a search right yeah it's easier
to find a buried treasure
oh yeah then to find the fight so it's
not like it used to be that I could just
sit there and turn it on
you ever see Bulgaria you know Korean
zombie against Edgar I got to get up at
6:15 in the morning to watch them fight
and [ __ ] Korea
my point being that I don't have the
time no more I watched one fight from
this this weekend's fight McGregor
against whatever they have now caught
Cowboys on whatever and boy cowboy look
like he aged Wow
five years from you know like this isn't
how long I haven't been like I just
watched the ko results online when I get
all over something and I watch it I see
these guys he's stuck around for too
long
well when I saw that I know you got to
break it down though cuz there's a way
of breaking it down and you got a look
at and you're not and you know I have a
podcast with Josh Thompson and it's
called weighing in and we talked about
hey hit this is Cowboys way of winning
this is McGregor I've got to go with you
know both guys going into the fight
either you know someone texted me before
and they say hey that's the first
pay-per-view on Pi in a long time you
know you know what do you think samurai
said Connors gonna walk the wrong you
know that that was my true feeling
Connor was gonna win that fight because
it's just the the what cowboy does and
his ability to deal with southpaw as I
knew he doesn't deal with south pause
well he doesn't see that left kick
well it lanced who frequently up high or
down to the body where he doesn't get
that elbow in he doesn't get that hand
up and he takes more than he should but
the whole thing cowboy is a guy that has
fought 50 sometimes and you can see the
progression of he started to take more
damage like you're talking in the last
10 fights he's taken more damage in
those fights than he did in the first 40
that's your difference when you're
watching a guy like a Demetrius Johnson
is now fighting over in one Fc and
Demetrius was the UFC flyweight champion
- no 10
defenses in a row and if you watch his
fights he I used to talk and tell people
time you've got to watch Demetrius
Johnson he had the lowest pay-per-view
numbers of any champion they had and it
was I would tell people you have got to
watch this guy because it wasn't so much
you know that he was you know knocking
guys it was his duty people couldn't
touch him he was never being damaged
against the very best people that they
could put against him he never took a
hard shot and so that's the guy when
you're looking you're saying yes he can
move on and he can move on and he can
move on to the next fight and the next
fight because he's not being damaged
it's like having you know a car you go
out and you buy a car and it's brand new
and you're trying to take care of it and
you're parking it away from other cars
because you don't want people at door
doing it and if you take care of it and
you don't allow things to happen to it
you change the oil and you do all these
things right that car can last you a
while but as soon as you start to
neglect it or as soon as someone even
though you're not neglecting it neglects
it by they run into the side of it they
run into the front of it now it's got
damage you take it in to get fixed but
it never comes back the way it was and
this is when I talk about guys in fights
many times they'll walk into the cage
and they're gonna walk out and Demetrius
it has done this so many times they will
walk out as good as they were when they
walked in did no damage at all and then
there's times that they'll walk out you
know what they got damaged a little and
they're leaving just a little bit of
themselves in that cage that they're
never gonna get back and then they're
gonna have the fights like cowboy has
had where he's leaving large chunks of
who he is in there he is accepting heavy
blows he's accepting damage that is
altering his ability for his brain to
control his body and those are the
fights when you have those and you take
these the fans love them the Robbie
Lawler versus the McDonald's they think
that's the greatest fight ever it was
for you as the fan it was for me as a
referee in there with them but for both
of those guys neither guy has been the
same
since that fight wave why why is that
because you can only crash that vehicle
so many times before it doesn't run or
it doesn't run the same fighting is
about timing and speed everyone talks
about being the bigger stronger guy that
isn't crap being the faster guy is
usually what is gonna get you a win
being the guy that has good timing the
ability to understand distance what
makes Conor
what he is is when he's training and
doing things right I've never seen a guy
who is better at understanding timing
and distance he's not as fast as people
say and he's not he doesn't have the
power that Joe Rogan will say that he
has it's that his timing and his
accuracy with the shot is outstanding he
understands that distance where he
allows you to throw your shot and it
just misses by 1/4 of an inch and he
steps in and he launches and he targets
one area he hits that area and he hits
it with power
based upon you not being able to move
back away from it now and he hurts you
and then he continues to hurt you in the
fight to the point he diminishes you and
he gets rid of you but that damage that
you accept in a fight sometimes you can
come back from it and sometimes you are
never the same and when your timing
starts to leave your ability to move
I'll tell you back when I was sparring
and my wife was the first one to say you
know you're getting hit too much I used
to spar with all the guys in my gym and
stuff and I would see their setup I knew
exactly what they were gonna try to do
and I would think I'm gonna move my head
this way inside and I'm gonna come
within my my counter and instead of I'd
see it and I would start to move and
boom it would hit me and it would hit me
and I was like I saw it I knew what was
happening and I couldn't get myself out
because Father time starts to take away
speed and speed it's just that fraction
of a second that makes something either
land solid or just slide by and miss and
when it's starting to land solid now
you're starting to be affected in the
fight in areas where you were never
affected before and it just
adds up I'm a member like just I've been
hanging out with Joe for a few years
that's just a couple at this point at
this point had been friends of Joe a few
years I don't know what the date is and
and follow [ __ ]
I followed comedy and I follow cocaine
another love [ __ ] Nazis turns me on
to a fight one night against he shows me
to find this house Bernard Hopkins
against Felix Trinidad oh yeah and Joe
remember that fight well broke that
fight down hell either and then of hope
a week later and of meeting Bernard
Hopkins on the best damn sports show and
he's a gentleman the drink guy I take
the picture I still got the picture of
my house does he sign them what he
signed on and I watched all his fights
and and then I saw fall the time start
to take over but that's not the
conversation the conversation was I
remember Felix Trinidad fought a while
after that and Joe said that that Felix
never fought the same is same again
never why what happened to you he in
that moment against one of the things
that made Bernard Hopkins so good was
Bernard started fighting late you know
he Bernard was in prison for robbery and
started fighting basically in prison and
when he came out of prison he started
training and picking fights and he was
he was very frugal with his money he was
cheap we would say but as soon as he
would have a fight he was so good
defensively and not taking damage that
he would fight on a Friday night he
would fight on a Saturday night and he
was back in the gym on Sunday or Monday
and training again and he would never do
this rollercoaster that a lot of
fighters do this is what like Conor got
into doing something made him this good
and then you start to expect that it's
just gonna be there forever it's not
it's gonna change and if you're not
training hard someone else is and
they're passing you by and Bernard
realized that and he just stayed on this
plateau he didn't eat
bad food he ate good and he just stayed
even though he's an older guy he stayed
at that plateau because he never stopped
training and he did not take serious
damage in fights he didn't start taking
damage in fights until he was in his 40s
that was amazing as far as what allowed
him to continue on with a career into he
was 50 years old Felix Trinidad was a
young guy and if you're gonna look at
the boxing why's the guy I would always
look at as Andre Ward from here in
California okay Andre is just a
phenomenal fighter phenomenal guy his
dad took him to the gym and Virgil Hill
Virgil was the guy that he took him to
and he said I want you to teach my son
how to box I mean I want you to teach my
son the art of hitting without getting
hit he didn't take his son into the gym
and tell Virgil I want you to make my
son tough because you can walk into the
gym and anyone I can't say anyone but
many people can be taught how to be
tough you know it's there's a there's a
system of thinking to it and you can say
hey I can I can put up with this and
you're gonna see a lot of boxers today a
lot of MMA guys you know Tim Elliott
just fought on the last UFC card 246 and
you fought on you know a guy named Oscar
and in the end to him Elliott is being
tough he's putting his hands down and
walking for it and just eating shot
after shot after shot now it looks great
and you think wow he's tough and it's
the dumbest thing you can do because
each of those shots is taking a part of
Tim Elliott away that he's not gonna get
back and so when he comes back into the
cage we'll say three months four months
five months six months later he's gonna
be just a little bit slower he's gonna
be able to absorb just a little bit less
and those little chinks that are coming
off of him you don't get back you cannot
get them back and guys like Andre Ward
learned early I want to be the guy that
hits and doesn't get hit a lot of people
don't like the way Floyd
mayweather fights alright but god damn
he's good because you can't hit him and
when you say you can't hit if people
have no idea what it's like to try to
hit somebody like a Floyd Mayweather you
can't you think you know you're throwing
and he's just little tiny movement and
that's why he has been as good as he has
been throughout a career undefeated at
50 you know how much damage have you
seen Floyd Mayweather take you haven't
you've seen him take a couple of good
shots but overall in a fight he never
takes that quantity of damage
that starts to alter him as a fighter
and in in that fight you were talking
about with Bernard Hopkins and Felix
Trinidad Felix got beat down by a guy
that he didn't understand how to be
offensive against because Bernard is
great defensively he'll throw his shots
in he'll it'll break the rules of boxing
to make it to where I have the referee
now separate me to the distance I want
to get back to I I did my damage you
didn't damage me at all let me do that
again and he just keeps repeating that
process and when you're Trinidad you're
trying to land that big shot and you're
taking all of these shots trying to land
that one big shot and it just never
happens and eventually you can't make it
happen and eventually you take so much
damage in that fight this is the fight
that alters you as a fighter for the
rest of your career and that's what
happened to him how much of it now do
you think is like the the marketing game
where you can sell the fight and make it
seem like it's gonna be more exciting
and then you have a plan so you don't
you don't get hit but you make it seem
like it's gonna be a brawl and like good
that that was the whole selling point of
McGregor cowboy yeah that's good I
didn't see a brawl that's a blast I'm
asking I didn't see a brother they
didn't sell me no bro I had two picks on
that on that fight yeah either it was
gonna go five rounds yeah no they were
gonna kill each other oh he was gonna
beat him up in the first round yeah that
was my prediction either or yeah
either they went five rounds and you
know cowboy used the 20 years experience
he had and said this is my last fight
I'm gonna go in there and fight like a
man out of prison you know cowboy had
all this [ __ ] and you know I was war
like I said I was working like they had
quality and Lee goes you didn't miss
nothing 40 seconds it was all Atkins and
then I went home and pulled on YouTube
and it was like kind of on the
embarrassing side well and but and this
is the whole thing as we talked about
you know one fight can alter your career
one shot one punch one kick one elbow
one knee one shoulder strike in that one
altered that fight from that moment on
it was over and it can happen in the
very first round in the very first ten
seconds of the fight it can happen in
the fifth round at 4:59 it's the shot
that puts you down but it only takes one
to alter who you are yeah III took a lot
of offense from a reporter named Steve
innate Smith who was part of that
telecast who said cowboy quit all right
that is one of the most ridiculous
statements anybody can say when
especially if you've never fought and
understanding what it takes to go out
there and I will tell you and I've
talked about cowboy for years about
being his referee going in the back and
he's a mess in the back but every time
he stepped out into that cage he turns
it on and it's a mentality and he just
got hit was so he didn't even know it
was a shoulder he thought it was an
elbow strike he never saw it he had a
broken nose and a broken orbital from
that fight in 40 seconds okay now I am
telling you get hit and have your nose
broken
okay now you can't breathe out of it and
your eyes are watering and now break
your orbital and I can guarantee you
when you break your orbital you don't
see either you see nothing out of the
eye or you see blur and now you're
completely affected and it's the storm
isn't stopping because you got hurt that
storm is intensifying to put you away
and it just happens you know and cowboy
has put people away fast and he got put
away fast by McGregor because he got hit
with a shot
that one shot altered him and from that
point it was you know downhill for him
and it can happen but when we have
reporters out there talking about oh he
quit well Steven Lee Smith comes from
the basketball school shame on whoever
even having a month absolutely thing
it's like when they have embarrassing
it's like when they have the other guy
from NFL sports show up to big black guy
I love them on the NFL don't put them on
the USC there's 20 guys you get okay I
don't give a [ __ ] get one of the
trainers that speech at Brazilian at
least he knows the game yeah I didn't I
didn't hear I know that Stephen H Smith
got a bunch of stuff I follow his
basketball stuff and his other stuff
knows but I think he knows dick of dick
don't put him in exactly why would you
do that what was Dominick Cruz will be
busy in San Diego perfect what the [ __ ]
he's in the desert and in his razor man
you mentioned another fight that we've
all seen as fans and I knew when I
watched him at Bellator that he wasn't
the same guy anymore that's Rory
MacDonald yeah and now he's in the PFL
looking for answers that aren't there
anymore
sometimes where you have that fight that
it's it takes everything out of you he's
had multiples of the emotion and that's
that's the real thing you know Rory if
you look at some of the fights that he's
had in that fight he the second fight he
had with Lawler people have no idea what
was going on in that fight and they have
no idea what Rory MacDonald was dealing
with during that fight now now Robbie
had you know he had a sliced lip he had
about a three and a half inch gash from
an elbow on top of his head
he had things going on too but Rory in
the very first round had his nose broken
and it was broken the point he could not
breathe out I mean you can see any was
aspirating blood for the entire fight so
you would see him come out in the
beginning of the round and he was he was
light and he was light and Robbie up and
he was winning that fight and then near
the end of the rounds he would tail off
and then he had a really good third
round and he tried to get rid of Robbie
in that third round and it took
everything he had because his body was
not able to take all the oxygen that
he's breathing in and distribute it
through you know his body into his
muscles to make them that lactic acid
stay away because his lungs were
absorbing blood it wasn't that he's
drinking blood it's not that he's
swallowing blood he's aspirating these
little tiny blood droplets that are
going into as long as what you're taking
his lungs and making them now in
effective in distributing that oxygen
through his body and he went through
that for four rounds and kept trying and
took an incredible beating and then you
look at the beating that he took against
Douglas Leeman in his first fight
against Douglas take a look at his leg
his leg the muscle actually separated
from the bone okay and is never going
back
okay the fascia split there's a there's
a sheathing that covers the muscle
that's called the fascia it got so
swollen that it split and there was so
much hemorrhaging on that shin and that
muscle to the front of his shin area
that the bone actually the muscle split
off of the bone and now he's got you can
see as he fights soon when he fights for
the PFL you're gonna see that he has
this lump already there and it's
actually separated from the bone he's a
different fighter and that's because of
the battles that he's had and he's gonna
have those problems coming up to the
pitcher had the mouths with Frank Yeager
Gray Maynard neither became exactly take
a look he never came whenever from the
moment that he's fighting for the
lightweight title against Frank he puts
on that first round a lot of people say
that's a 10-7 round it's at least ten
eight and Frankie you know stays in the
fight that fight Gray Maynard was never
the same fighter after that fight and he
that was a draw it was a draw and he
lost so much in that fight well I'm
sorry
because warring them but with any
fighter because Rory came out a year or
two ago on city then nobody had it
mentally in them about that like a
mental game were like you trained for
two three months but everything you have
into it and then you get beat
in front of millions of people like even
if you win that has to take a mental
toll on you it you know the part that
really takes a mental toll that's so
hard especially today with you know
social media and the people out there
and I try to tell every fighter that if
there's one thing you know you kind of
talk about it you know how stupid were
you when you were young compared to what
you are now you know and I talk about
all that man if I if I go back to being
25 dude I do it no heartbeat as long as
I didn't have to have the brain I had
when I was 25 because I was an idiot uh
you know I made terrible decisions all
the time I was stupid as hell if I could
have my brain now and b25 ho ho hello
yeah God doesn't do that though yeah
there's a balance in life and you take a
look at what is occurring for these guys
and how much damage they're taking at
times and just their ability to fight
through it and then come back and do it
again it's not it takes a special person
Rory is a person who you know he's dead
he's he's a completely different man
he's a young kid fighting started when
he's basically 16 years of age fighting
professionally gets into the UFC at a
young age puts on a great performance
against Carlos Condit but loses it right
at the end of the fight and it gets
topped with 11 seconds I think left
after he had won the first two rounds
most people say and came out and started
starching people think of the people
that he put he threw Nate Diaz around up
in Toronto you know he's suplexed him
three times in a row he just put him
past whipping on and put an ass-whooping
on BJ Penn walk through tyron woodley
you know all these people but then he
found that one guy in Robbie that it
just didn't work for him didn't work for
him in the first or in the second fight
then he had you know his battles with
Lima here in Bellator when he was there
man he took huge damage and then he
becomes a father and he gets married and
he's a different person he just doesn't
have that same thing and I was the one
that did the interview he says I don't
know if I if I can do this anymore and
trust me I'm sitting there going hey I
understand but I've got to do this
interview with them and you know are you
thinking about maybe this is you know
and this
someone's telling you you know what I'm
not sure it's over it's over
you know you Yuri there are a hundred
percent in when it comes to fighting
fighting is not a game we play football
we play basketball we play baseball
Fighting's the hurt business and you've
got to be 100 percent in and if you're
not walk away from it because the damage
that it can do to you and permanent
damage that can do to you for the rest
of your life you know you're never gonna
get those years back it's so weird you
know I used to when I first moved to the
valley I went to what we tie school and
it was filled with who I thought were
fighters nothing that made a difference
for me cuz I'm gonna fight I'm just
going after Jenna like sense and I would
ask these guys what is your next find
though I find I am a 5-month and they'd
have the UFC shorts and the shirt the
greased hair and you know and I trained
UFC bro but this is why I said to you as
a manager even would come you know about
a month and a half ago I was on a show
and they were comparing the movie the
Joker took a tour parallels to stand-up
comedy what you go through as a comic
you know I won't do you snap
how long to you move how long to you
once you see behind the curtain now how
do you react to it because I tell people
all the time here you want to get to
this level but once you get to that
level you think it stops there's even
more drama you know it's acting kind of
wouldn't come over for interviews I'm
fighting the championship [ __ ] you want
to interview me now I got to go sit with
a guy that is doing an interview for the
school paper
really so I get all that
oh yeah I get all that's part of the
that's part of the game but it's like
you have a window when I came to Iowa I
gave myself a window yeah and I was like
if this doesn't happen at this time
there's no reason for me to be here and
something would happen and then
something kept tapping arista : why did
it happen it happened because I kept
working a bingo
see I don't understand
the peaks and valleys I don't like this
comics I'll go on a six-month tour and
then they disappear for whatever that
kind of throws me off I like to always
be in the game I try to at least do five
spots a week even though if I'm not
working I'm not working on the road I
still go out try out two new jokes yeah
you know go out one night pissed
one night I go up and smoke a joint try
out you know you're always in the game I
don't like the ups and the downs of the
game I did not like what went on with
Connor
because life went by Dustin's got
tougher Tony got tougher yeah we've got
tougher I know you got a hundred million
but these guys against you know I came
from the old basketball baggage when I
was 12
this is how I looked at life you gotta
do what he ain't doing it's midnight I
know that [ __ ] ain't practicing
I'm gonna go ah damn well she said you
know so it's a mental aspect we're
fighting if right now you came to me
today in your 22 and like again I tell
you this is a three to three and a half
to I'll extend it to four window okay by
the time you're 28
I want you outta here to end with a
martial art you can do something sort of
service that you can always readjust if
you're having those four years go
exactly like you want to you don't get
damaged do another four-year plan you
know how can we up that in this next
four years or three years and that's
fine you can do it or you can have a
tour you know I've taken a lot of damage
in these these four years and maybe it
is time to get out and that's what I was
you know I was trying to say with you
know Rory it's a matter of when you when
you're looking at guys that come out and
they fight one of the hardest things
about Fighting's is you've got 15
minutes or 25 minutes to perform and
sometimes when you come out it is your
night man you're feeling good you go out
there and everything's working and you
feel fast and some nights you go out
there and your legs feel like lead you
feel slow you feel sluggish you feel
like I don't see things as well and if
you don't perform
well in those 15 minutes 25 minutes you
have to hear about it for months before
you'll get another chance to undo and
come back and prove hey I still got it
because everyone's talking about that
last fight and so you got to live with
that last fight for a long time it's not
like you can just step back on the horse
you know you talked about your view of
comedy and your what you're saying is
your view is you need repetitions the
more repetitions you get the more
consistent and the better you'll be
that's the way I always looked at it
with refereeing and I tell guys you need
repetitions you can't be the part-time
guy that oh I only do the big fights
because you're gonna [ __ ] it up because
if you're only doing those fights and
you have this giant space in between
them where you have a month or two
months and you don't referee you're not
in there and you're not able to keep
that timing and that level of
concentration and that ability to see
things it starts to like any perishable
skill it starts to wane away and I
talked about you know all the time do I
used to do 115 to 120 shows as a referee
a year that shows that's not fights you
know and so I would do anywhere between
10 you know maybe down to three fights
depending upon the size of the show that
many for each one of those shows but
that meant I was working every week
multiple times a week and it kept me
where I never had to worry about the
little things it kept me on top you know
and that's what you're talking about
with the comedy but it's a fighter you
can't do that you know only thing I have
an advantage of the fighter is an AI
don't get punched in the face and I have
a beat tomorrow to redeem myself yep if
I go to the comments don't eat a bag of
dicks on a Monday yeah you better bet
ten for ten I'm gonna go back the other
Tuesday smack it and try to get it and
if I don't get it on Tuesday Wednesday
forgot Wednesday's the day I'm just
saying the wording wrong there's a joke
wall I didn't fake for me I compared
hearts and something you compare are you
do a you do a set
and then sometimes the audience just
that's not the audience that's not the
one that gets you and the next night
you'll get one them and they're just
tuned into you everything you say what
is the thing that I don't like I know I
use those excuses early on and once I
moved away I took that excuse away every
audience is the same it's how you come
out there it's how you face them you
know [ __ ] off the guy who sent the
pictures of his dick to his trainer the
football guy yeah Brett Favre allof but
for his massage therapist whatever he
did whatever he ever did I always have a
most respectful to he did something I
don't think I could do well I did it I
did it
I mind here his father died he got a
call he went on to five touchdowns at
the game of his [ __ ] life you know
most people in between whatever you know
I was on a plane to Vegas excited to
play Treasure Island and before the
plane takes off I got a call that my
friend hung himself and I got a flyer in
the plane and get there and you know it
was he my best friend my knew him for a
long time was I like a fat chick in the
church
take me Lord take me now I wasn't daddy
I'd do a chauffeur you know you [ __ ]
people and I went out there and I gave
him the best shot I could and I felt
great because I kept thinking somewhere
along the line I'm gonna fall apart
somewhere along knowing I'm gonna cry up
on this stage in front of these people
it's not gonna be a problem they're
gonna love it they're gonna sympathize
but I can't and you know the mental
aspect and all this that we do whether
it's fighting or stand up your mental
has to be so strong you have to have
such good people around you people that
trust you know I heard you ever watch
the Elvis document around HP I was a
two-parter oh yeah [ __ ] father did I
he called the colonel the guy he called
the colonel
for the night you know [ __ ] to come
out there's a there's a [ __ ]
audiotape that he said listen there's
Elvis these he's all [ __ ] up on drugs
we don't know how much time we got left
with him let's just put him on the road
and milk him to [ __ ] dies you know oh
you know when you hear that brutal you
you you see the realities of fighting
you see the realities of calmly you
remember when Muhammad Ali fought at
forty something and he should have been
fighting and he took a beating he did it
for money absolutely no you do it for
money you do it so this is why you have
a fighter you have to sit him down and
go you know first of all I don't agree
with the $5,000 about fight you know
that should they pay over at the UFC
5,000 that's a loser that you lost money
just between your trainer I have taxes
and the boxing coach you lost money
there's no way you make more money
uber and forget you got it summer
Barbara how I equip the [ __ ] selling
real estate online you know whatever the
[ __ ] I'm not mad I love that you know
I'm not gonna rely on you I'm gonna rely
on myself I'm gonna go I'm gonna go sell
real estate you my sell a lot of houses
after like after that fight with khabib
like using it as a platform like you
have to be smart but that's it's
interesting what you're talking about
and it's I'm sure you have to deal with
it in comedy and I don't know if you
have to deal with everything but how do
you choose how to have who to have
around you because what if you get the
Elvis guy what if you get Aaron
Hernandez is mom when he's in jail
saying if only you'd given me a million
dollars that was said that I was like
bad I'm like you can't trust anybody
these like it spreads wild you know when
I spoke to you I've been you blew my
mind the last time you came on the show
because you said something that nobody
had ever even mentioned in this whole 20
years since this happened it was the oj
thing yeah and you said that i really
wonder about the safety the impulsive
this you know people follow him on
Twitter they say he's [ __ ] hilarious
like that he has no remorse at all like
he's just yeah you know happy Mother's
Day had no [ __ ] like that that's you
know we're looking at the behavior
Antonio Brown yeah we're looking at that
not sad
we're looking at all these behaviors and
you know for me I thought CT came after
you retired I thought that CTE came when
you were 35 if you took a lot of blows
that I had you I'm looking at without
hurting anybody's feelings of starting a
war I'm looking at six guys they used to
be UFC fighters now that oh my god you
could hear it and they talk in their
patterns already Oh easy and I was like
wow whatever maybe it's me maybe I smoke
too much pot watch the Aaron Hernandez
there and yes I was blown away on his
murders it's to pay the inners immature
earnest I was the same person when I was
23 what shocked me the most about that
whole documentary was episode three
spoiler alert go [ __ ] your mother if you
have a watch that's about for ten days
alright and you haven't watched in years
if you haven't watched you should be
shot and [ __ ] home I'm sorry but when
they said the amount of CTE he had he
played his last game when he was 23
years old Wow he died with his 27
corrects close their eyes and they did
the brain the autopsy so now I know I'm
not stupid that CT probably grows it
grows even after you stop taking bumps
to the head it's gonna continue on what
it contains the terror the terror it's
called a taro protein it starts to
attack your brain and that taro proteins
just starts to eat the actual brain
itself and that's where you're starting
to get these bigger and bigger crevasses
then it just starts to deteriorate the
brain it's it's insidious when you look
at what that
disease does and a disease that until
Michael Webster who played for the
Pittsburgh Steelers he was the center
you know Center for Terry Bradshaw who
we watch every you know Sunday when the
NFL's on you're seeing you know Terry is
he still lucid you know can you know
crack jokes you know sometimes he'll say
things you go oh he's gonna get in
trouble for that but you know he's you
know the guy that was the guy protecting
him in front was the first guy that was
diagnosed by you know the dr. Omalu in
hey this guy has a disease that we don't
know about and CTE repetitive blows to
the head you know and and if you go back
mail Mike Webster they tried to portray
it in the movie concussion you know this
guy was he was you know he was torturing
himself trying to think right his entire
family left him because they couldn't be
around him because he just was this guy
you know they didn't understand and he
had these rages and he tried to you know
use things he was pulling his teeth out
of his head you know and you're looking
you go my god and now back then we
didn't know about you know things we
didn't know that obviously we kind of
knew hey you know boxers when boxers get
older they get what we call you know one
punch drunk or and then it turned into
pugilist yet dementia and you know
football players it really wasn't that
much and then all of a sudden oh no
football players are prevalent with this
problem and all of these in fact the
Pittsburgh Steelers were Webster Terry
long you know Straczynski all these guys
that played with the Steelers you know a
tough team all had this and they're all
killing themselves you and then jr. sale
kills himself shoots himself Dave
Duerson who played for the Chicago Bears
for the 86 you know for you know the 46
defense he shoots himself in the chest
to take his life while leaving a note
saying I want you to check my brain and
he's got huge CTE issues this is a guy
that had a had a degree from the
University of Notre Dame and all
couldn't you know add up numbers
couldn't do anything that made sense
then jr. say out does the same thing jr.
say odd himself in the heart in the
chest saying I want you to look at my
brain and you know obviously he had a
major problem with CTE and and that's
why he was having the depression but you
get to Aaron Hernandez who you're
talking about
you're talking about a guy who played
football as a peewee as a high school
football player as a collegiate football
player for three years and then a couple
years in the pro and at the age of 27
they say that his brain was that of
people that have died that are over 45
years of age 45 to 55 was the only
people that were close to the amount of
damage that Aaron Hernandez had at the
age of 27 when he died that's crazy
it [ __ ] [ __ ] me up all last weekend
because I started thinking about how
many times I'm gonna hit the head but my
Pete my PTSD don't come from [ __ ]
it's that habit that comes from you know
losing parents and that type of yeah at
least I I know I am and I I really focus
on my notebook and writing and you know
but I think of 23 and I look at these
kids getting into the you have seen it
yeah like that just opened my eyes to so
many thing 23 younger 23 and he already
[ __ ] at it and it was on its way do
you think it was responsible for his
behavior I think it had a huge amount of
yeah there's no doubt that it led to now
that doesn't take away from the
responsibility that doesn't take away
from the act itself I'm not giving him
an excuse but the inability to
rationally think you know look at they
say that that you know especially men
you know the human brain is not fully
developed until its 25-year twenty five
years of age and sometimes they say even
a little bit longer for men because
we're idiots okay and I'll kind of go
along and agree with that he was 23 when
he stopped playing football he had his
brain hadn't even
developed and had this amount of CTE and
it's I don't my dad's you know is older
and he's always yelling at me about what
they're doing to football and the other
you know candy and making them you know
put vacation and football is ridiculous
and I go dad
you know you need to understand this has
to be done it's the only way for
football to survive and they have all
live it well it might not but you know
it's like back in his day you know he
was the leather helmet days and you
actually had a leather helmet when he
first started playing now I read an
article I was very interested in that
and I started one night you know on the
road I do this [ __ ] on the road this is
what I do on the road not when I'm
around my [ __ ] family as I go down
foxholes and I guess somebody did a
study and they said that when they were
wearing the leather helmets there was
less head injuries because they weren't
yeah the EDS
as a weapon you know that's exactly what
I'm talking about I didn't know I had to
put that all together through reading
and whatever my dad talks about you know
the first time I was knocked out well it
was the first time they actually had
hard helmets he goes he says in a house
receiving a thing he says that I caught
the ball and the first thing I saw was
this white with a green stripe and it
hit me in the face you know and because
I went to the wrong huddle and you know
back then it was hey you know suck it up
right back in the game yeah because they
didn't know you know and we didn't know
the things back then and I'm not saying
when it comes to guys you know like the
dick buck is's of the world and all the
old football players have played in that
era of the 60s and 70s 80s hey we didn't
know obviously we knew all right
football is not real healthy for you as
far as later on you're gonna have all
these joint issues and all these but no
one knew it was gonna change you as a
human being because your brain is who
you are now you know at least with
fighting football any of them hockey you
haven't you know this isn't activity if
I'm gonna do this it ain't healthy it's
not healthy for me and this can
absolutely affect who I'm gonna be later
on
now the
is it's that decision is usually made by
a young person and as young people were
not that bright we don't think about the
future coz you know I never thought I
was gonna live past 35 I'd throw this
dirty seven okay there you go and I was
like you know there's no way I take too
many chances I do too many dumb things
you know you know but here I am it you
know you're a 57 years old I'm still
here and I want more you know but you're
not gonna make the best decisions and
that's why I know what you're talking
about with have a plan
hey have a plan is absolutely right have
I always tell people you know look at
dreams are great but they don't become a
reality until you write them down and
then it becomes a goal well right then
it's a goal I worked for a guy that used
to say what do you want real I mean I
still talk to this guy today that's how
much it makes sense and what I write it
he's called The Godfather who says this
guy's what do you want it's like what do
you want I want you know most people say
I want a Corvette ok ok that's great you
want to call that I gonna get that car
but wall of them a [ __ ] get a job
it's [ __ ] the 4th place I'm gonna
save up for eight months in that well
that's a great plan but you Mazal shoot
yourself in the [ __ ] head yep you
know I want you to break it down for me
completely for three months you're gonna
get two part-time jobs you're gonna put
your second check away whatever the [ __ ]
your dream is and that's what he would
make you do yeah I want to sell how many
cars you want to sell this my 14 how you
gonna do that I gotta talk to 220 people
to sell 14 cars I gotta make 20 phone
calls a day
I gotta send 20 letters a day he would
make you do that yeah and then I started
using it towards comedy what do I want
him comedy I want to be an emcee what's
an emcee 15 minutes what do I need to do
I need to write three because I know if
I write three only one of is good so
that me I'm saying yeah you have to
break it down that much with fighting
it's the same thing absolutely with
fighting it's like listen you're gonna
win
- I don't care whether you do decision
or knockout a submission the third one
we're gonna get you a top ten you know
you go to the top ten will get you this
and buy you six fight you're fighting
for the championship money I should be
able to get you two million and three
point two million in endorsements now
you you got to protect yourself you know
you're gonna go for the title twice and
those two years I'm gonna get you this
this and this and this
we're gonna take this money I'm gonna
put it in a money market we're gonna buy
your house to save on taxes we're gonna
get you the hell LC out of out of
Nashville Oklahoma know when Valvano won
the championship day here what did he
make them do first
I don't know what he made him do first I
just know cuz he's told me before cut
the nuts down
first they have practice he got ladders
and he made them cut the Nets down we
won the championship don't like what you
talkin about coach we won this practices
all get on ladders and each other's
shoulders and razor blade than that down
why they give him a taste of that to
give them a taste of what its gonna be
this is what we're doing this is what we
don't have it's on you right now
we're cutting the Nets down March but it
would have madness explain this watch
madness the 31st we'll cut in these nets
down and he had a plan you know and a
man without a plan is not a man right
plant planted [ __ ] simple and I see
that we've watched tremendous great
fighters come and go and now you gotta
sit there and go what the [ __ ] are they
doing because at one time this is before
the UFC ran the Nike deal they were
getting 250,000 and 300,000 150s those
deals are done one of those guys doing
today are they teaching jiu-jitsu 400 a
class I know that what's his name with
the one I is working with the army you
know the one that uh Michael Bisping
no the one that got jabbed to death by
by the Canadian College act talking Josh
Koscheck
yeah he's work he's helping like
troops and stuff like that but what
about the rest of the guys what the [ __ ]
are they doing well yeah and that's
that's the whole this is what I'm saying
that's why you're talking about what you
you know you set those goals and you've
got to you you've got to put things down
on paper in my opinion the same as what
you're doing because you that way it's
no longer just a dream it's a goal and
okay now that I've set this goal now
what's the next step to get this and so
would defend this title I want to say
that Anderson went on a run of let's say
16 fights or so after the wintertime you
know clothes yeah you gotta remember how
many con made you so 10 defenses would
have been enough Oh will it be enough
him and his family would have had enough
money oh he had plenty of money that's
not your money and but then you get into
the aspect of the drug ten its defenses
in 16th Street were straight ones and
even broke steam my man knocked him out
Long Island yep Chris wife then he came
back and he broke this how many how many
wins did he have since since that lost I
don't know one one winning it was
against Derek Brunson and many people
thought he lost that one it was a
decision he never really had a good
fight after that why he wasn't the same
fighter you know and this is not that's
not taking and saying you advise you a
fighter at that point look oh you try
what you want to do you try I'm I want
you to have a future and I want you to
think straight and I want you to know
what 2+2 is at the age of 65 you try you
know I want you to do a half a Rubik's
Cube and I'm saying I want you to do but
part that the other part of the exactly
the other part of the equation is not
just the money it's it's it is your ego
and it's you know there's a drug you
know and fighting is it's it's addictive
it really is it's no different than any
other addiction and it's not so much you
know the the actual
fight itself that's addicting or the
training that's so addicting it is the
camaraderie that you get from all the
people that you are working with and
being with that's addicting and then the
addiction of walking out you know and
this when I talk about like with cowboy
you know cowboy did they just did a
beautiful thing the UFC put out with
cowboy talking about getting to the
arena and getting ready for the fight
and he talks about I throw up every time
and he did I was back there with him it
looks like every time I worked it I was
like you know he would march around
going why am I doing this
I hate this you know in it and everyone
thinks of him as the guy anytime
anywhere let's go you know I just fought
this week let's fight next week
but he went through this process in the
back of goddamn because there's fear and
it's not fear of the guy across from you
it's fear of what happened to him
against Conor it's the fear of not
looking good it's the fear of having my
family and friends there and not
performing to the level that I can and
then I have to live with that and that's
what you know the fear you have but it's
when they walk out and that music is
playing and those fans are going crazy
and they're getting introduced that's a
drug you cannot inject smoke get
anywhere else there's only one way to
get it and that's to be that guy in that
big fight and once you've had it you
kind of want to have it again so it's
tough to walk away it is tough to walk
away you know you keep on thinking just
one more
what is just one what the [ __ ] do you
think I go through yeah you know when I
have to go to the Communists on a
Tuesday I look at that lineup and I go I
gotta go down and follow Rogel is
following the Leo who's following
Jeselnik who's following Ron White
who's follow that but one thing that
you're talking about and this is yeah
this is all of us Joey cocoa Diaz you
are one of the funniest [ __ ] I
have ever seen
hold on but you don't look at yourself
that way you look at your Rogen that way
and he is he's
you look at Ron White that way in a man
look at what you look at you know all of
them you go god Ari Shaffir
dude he's freaking funny you don't put
yourself in that same category and
that's the way we kind of look at
ourselves you know but yeah you are of
that caliber yes your fear is why I have
to take a long sigh here's good though
it's see that's what people don't
understand I take a little anxiety pill
open it put it in my top pocket I don't
take it before I leave the house because
I'm gonna need it right before I go
onstage you know for a while there when
I was first started headlining I would
wear long shirts out by 2x long people
go why because I would pee a little bit
little dot as you're announcing my but
what people don't understand is that
that fear is the hard-on it's good that
fear is the heart on the day you don't
have that fear anymore it's time for you
to quit yeah you know I'm so fearful
when I Drive to the comedy store I don't
put the radio on like that's how much
fear I have on the drive to the comedy
store I love when people call me know
hey you gonna let started I can I help
and we're is very seldom people I wanted
that call with yeah because they're
gonna drive me crazy
I have to go to the comedy store like
I'm [ __ ] gladiator when I walk in
there I gotta like get my water keep the
chitter-chatter down if I get into an
argument with somebody it would be great
but you can't are your people every day
at 57 when I was younger I would get I
would pick arguments at joe and re-read
ban and tell them that their phones were
all [ __ ] you all have matching phones
you should be ashamed of yourselves and
Joe know exactly what I was doing oh
yeah Joe knew Joe used to say let them
go all of them do if he slams you set
yourself up because I'm just getting
myself I would pick on the smallest
thing really [ __ ] water
get on you like I'm trying to do my best
water
what are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] and get
get a [ __ ] beer and I would just pick
on you and you go where'd that come from
he's about to go onstage let watch when
he gets off he's gonna pologize three
and I wasn't even I know forget and they
started doing it to me on purpose
hey Eddie at one time they all had the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] phone just had it be
like I didn't know a phone is [ __ ] yeah
you know somebody's not though it wasn't
an iPhone before like before my dad's
these guy I call it the burner parts the
it's the Sons of Anarchy burner phone
the flip phone yeah
ass cuz it's the only thing he could
figure out how to use I had a burner
phone like and I was still with Sprint I
was with Sprint but I always had like a
regular phone I didn't know and they'd
show up with the sake [ __ ] phone and
one day I'll never forget they all put
them like I yelled at I'm like the
Thursday night I go really
matching phones what a man coming and
then they figure that they're like oh
Joey these gets pissed at the phones so
they were all put their phones down at
the same time and they were all match it
and they were ticking about six minutes
of burning and I'm right before I get up
I go you know what what are you guys
just gonna start sucking dick once you
have matching phones what's next the
next step and it would just be me
getting fired up sometimes when I go to
the time you start go to the green room
if I have a show I normally get fired up
I go back there to get angry and then
without saying a word I go out behind
the stage as scared as I am cuz you know
like Tommy stores haunted
last time I was outside somebody tapped
me on the shoulder it is haunted it's
fun so I'm standing behind the main room
a lot of times I go on the green room I
say hello somebody's smoking and trying
to take to it so then something starts
to aggravate me it can be as simple as a
tee shirt unbuttoned a tee shirt
unbuttoned it could be a shotgun but it
could be as simple as a pair of orange
sneakers or just a tattoo something just
sets me off and that's when I excused
myself the Hawaiian soldier you know
like if you got hummus and chips I'll
flip
got piano over what if you really want
me to have a good set but hummus and
chips in my green house whatever table
it's on there's only go [ __ ] flying
and I'm probably only going on that
stage and just level the [ __ ] because
it's I like the mix that you set up man
I like I used to mix the fear with the
anger once I got older and I couldn't be
angry at people no more can the science
not cool Joey then how to deal with my
old fear yeah so when I go to the
Commish don't know how I sit in the back
and that's their talking [ __ ] about me
next guy who's coming up next oh I mean
I pop up you've never seen 300 pounds do
a burpee that I go I go up in the air
yeah I pulled my pants up and as they're
bringing me up I walked down and I'm
that I've asked fighters when I've had a
man hit before because I only have a 20
foot walk and I feel like I'm gonna die
yep like it's like I just ran 26 miles
and this is the last traveling man
[ __ ] what a drunk what a drug oh yeah
and I asked I've asked a lot of fighters
what is that walking the tunnel like
because I swear to God I would walk up
with you you're like ready and once I
saw that camera I would look at you I
forgot something the dress oh my god he
would see me driving on the 5 with my
full gear and an rap song and I'm still
I don't know how they do it I don't what
I see a fighter do walk down that time I
go ooh I'm getting anxiety just for him
because he's [ __ ] I would run out I
just tell you John I left home I left my
yacht might come another time no it's
not I mean go get it you know and you
wouldn't see Joey Diaz again yeah the
whole point of that all that I don't
care if it's in the comedy or in the
fighting realm fear is a good thing God
puts it in you for reasons it's to let
you know hey we have a problem or this
is important and I can't screw this up
but it's it's how you handle the fear
that determines what you are if you
allow fear to stop you
from doing the things that you need to
do to take that next step to better
yourself to better your family then your
allowing something to occur that should
never have encouraged is the person that
when filled with fear makes that 20-foot
walk to the stage gets on that mic and
says what's up [ __ ]
oh I'm packing right oh yeah exactly but
it's courage that gets you to that point
where now you start as soon as you start
all the fear starts to go away like it's
so funny when I watch a fight I'll watch
a fight completely different than how
people watch a fight yeah I'll watch a
fight unfortunately that's my life I
pick a guy and I make believe on that
guy and I know for me to get started I'm
not to get punched in the face four
times I can't just start swinging I have
to get aggravated I got a seal in blood
I gotta go all right [ __ ] is
this your mum when she shot him in the
pinky toe in Harlem that's shot her in
the pinky telling us you came back with
a switchblade that's me you gotta get me
warmed up but how many punches can you
take you know what if you take four and
you get knocked the [ __ ] out can like I
couldn't come out just throwing heat
like that but because of fear I think I
would just jump on a [ __ ] I
would pull Georgia mouth-to-mouth that
just run at the [ __ ] I had to pick
the Cuban what's up with that no I'm not
saying because he's also that's the way
I would have to yeah do it my fears just
like he did against Ben yeah just run
out that beautiful that was a great
thing a lot of people look at that and
they think oh man he just did that it's
like yeah he just did that but he didn't
just do that he planned when he worked
at that he practiced that he went he
watched what Ben does he watched how you
know he dips his head when all of a
sudden something's coming you see he'll
start to dip his head like a lot of
wrestlers do if they're in a shot and he
planned it and and it's the fact that he
did all of those things and then made it
work man that's what you're looking to
go dude my hat is off to you that was
stupendous in fact we had like I said I
have a cast with Josh Thompson we're
doing
top five knockouts top ten knockouts top
ten fights of the year and my number one
knockout is Jorge Masvidal against Ben
Askren who does 19 man look at he that
was against a guy and I'm not telling
you that Ben was not a lesser fighter
comparatively to younger in his career
you know he's he had hip problems he was
getting older still undefeated at that
time and Maz Vidale gist starched him in
it's less than five seconds I don't care
you know what the time says that was
enough time for Jason Herzog to go fight
and master all kind of gear war and
comes running boom and as soon as that
knee touched that fight was over you
know there was nothing more I don't care
when the timer stopping I don't care
what Jason you know waved his hands off
as soon as that knee touched and you saw
been going over he was stiff that fight
was over and it was really like three
four seconds it's just incredible are
you repping at all anymore no zero
nothing the last MMA fight you ain't
home no more on the side I hold on the
side or anything you know I stopped for
a reason and it was you know a lot of
people as you know why you know why
don't you still think it's like there's
reasons why I stopped and you got it you
got to be honest with yourself about
everything and if people ask me do you
miss it of course I do
I loved it I loved being the guy that
you know sometimes fights you'd go in
there and you're lucky just to be a
Nephite but you don't do anything and
it's all easy and all good and then
you'll have the fights like the you know
the McDonnell Lawler fight or a fight
like that where you have all these
problems that the fans don't even see
but it's your ability to make it work
it's the fights where you talk that
ringside physician out of stopping the
fight and allowing that fight to go on
and it's a classic or you know just all
those things I will never ever not want
to be that guy in in the cage but there
came a point you know I had had three I
got had three neck surgeries and you
know from jiu-jitsu I let people do
things to me it was always the stupid
thing and this is where you know we
talked about being stupid it was the guy
that said oh I've got this hole no one
can get out of this you know or
you know I do it like this and USA all
right come on show me and you can't tap
because it hurts you know you've got to
sit there and you got to take it and say
yep no it doesn't work sorry yeah and so
over time I got injured I ended up
having a couple of discs replace than my
neck and they put a cage around that and
then I had a real problem and I went
paralyzed on one side I couldn't lift a
fighter's hand with my left hand it got
that bad and then it switched over to
the right and I was just deteriorating
and I you know had two surgeries within
two weeks and I took some time off and I
came back and I came back it was
November 4th I won't forget it November
felt 4th of 2017
it was the George st. Pierre versus
Michael Bisping fight in New York City
and I did the the first championship
fight that was on the card was Joanna
Jen chieh chick against rose namajunas
and you watch that fight and it gets to
a point and I was healing but I mean I
wasn't I didn't have any strength or
anything and I used to like you know if
a fighter was you know I was doing
something and ending the fight and I was
in South you see me pick him up with one
arm and I I just pick him up and pull
him off to the side there was nothing
they could do to stop it and it made it
very clean and very easy for me to do
and I realized as all of a sudden
Joanna's down on the ground and roses
going after and I'm thinking I don't
know if I can pick her up and you know
she was a a small female fighter and I
thought to myself I don't want to run
into her because I don't want to hurt
her you know by putting my body weight
into her and her so I just touched her
and I went you know stop and I smacked
her and she stopped and it looks really
clean but in my head I said I'm done I
can't do that that's not gonna work all
the time that's I am I'm putting the
fighter in danger if he now that fighter
doesn't stop now I'm doing something
that I've taken extra time it's not good
and I came home and I talked to my wife
and then I gotta figure something out
and just you know how fate is I got a
call from Scott Coker like two weeks
later you know well no probably I'm
sorry a month and a half later saying
hey
I want to know do you want to a audition
for a commentator with Bellator and I
was like I had an ass for that I hadn't
thought about that and I was like are
you kidding so you you have you know
Jimmy Smith was the guy at the time he
goes yep no Jimmy's gonna be moving on
we have a spot and we're gonna be
auditioning some guys wanna know if you
wanna do it
Jimmy is working on Sirius radio you
know he went to the UFC was working with
Fox but that year that he was there he
only had a one-year contract and they
switched over to ESPN and they decided
they wanted all fighters that were known
to fight in the UFC and so Jimmy was uh
you know not picked back up and so he
had some opportunities but he's been
doing serious radio he's got us show and
it does like Invicta and stuff now but
he's doing okay old question for you
because it happens to fire this happens
to all of us do you feel I mean you look
great you look better than you've ever
looked well thank you sir
do you think at some point age your
eyesight movement affect you from being
a good reference absolutely okay yeah
and that's part of I don't want the guy
to come in and go oh yeah and I tell
guys all the time you can see it and
part of when I went to home I said I
didn't want to be the person I'd been
doing it now for 25 years okay longer
than just about anybody and I said I
don't want to be the person where
someone's saying you need to retire did
you start with boxing or MMA no I
started with MMA you know I started day
one I was not a referee I had no idea
how to referee and it was you know my
entire progression through refereeing
was I was the bad guy you know no boxing
official wanted to talk to me if I if I
went to once a can I had can I talk to
you about hey how you do this why do you
do that
I was persona non grata you know I was
the guy that did that crazy fighting
then you know we let people die that's
the way they looked and so I had to
learn on my own and I learned by always
going back and watching say okay how can
I do that better what's gonna work in
this situation and there's so many
things that you're seeing guys do now
that I came up with as something would
happen in the fight it wasn't good you
know Tito Ortiz was fighting Chuck
Liddell the first time it was at UFC 47
and first round is going it's kind of
close but right near the end of the
first round
Chuck throws a high kick and he goes
after Tito and he's starting to you know
land some shots and Tito's kind of
covering up and just before it happened
I had heard we have the ten-second
clacker just like in boxing you know and
so I heard it and at the time I never
did anything with it you know I just but
I would count back in my head
ten nine eight so I knew when to get
close to get him between the fighters so
there wasn't something thrown after the
sound of the horn and Chuck goes after
him and all of a sudden the crowd just
wah and it just cuts its building and
the decibel levels just blowing through
the roof on it and I get to one zero and
I don't hear anything but the roar
there's no horn well the horn that was
being and hit but no one could hear it
and I go 101 zero and I stopped and I
came in between them and because Tito
didn't hear the horn and Chuck didn't
hear the horn and I'm saying stop Tito
thought I actually stopped the fight on
him you know saying the fights over you
know which wasn't it was just the end of
the round and Tito you'll see kind of
you know I didn't even know it at the
time he kind of shows my it shows me in
the back a little bit
my wife says why did he shove you and I
go lean mean he showed me I didn't even
know but you know I lead him off to the
stool and I realized hey there has to be
something done in that ten seconds I'm
gonna tell the timekeeper from now on
every time that you know you do that
clap you're gonna see me point your
direction and so I just do a little
point and that's telling that timekeeper
through side line in which basically hey
I heard it I know that there's ten
seconds left now I don't say it to the
fighters anything in some referees will
tell the fighters you have ten seconds
you know stop with the bell or whatever
they gonna say I never did that because
I was like I'm not here to tell the
fighters go after in the ten seconds
but that little point then I would tell
them if I don't point I want you to hit
that clacker again and hit it until I do
point because that would tell them okay
now he knows that this is coming to an
end because I want to be in position to
end the round so those are just what we
call mechanics of reffering and I came
up with so many little things on how to
do something how to stop something how
to break a hold all the little things
you know Tito you know again you look
and you go - Tito Ortiz when he fought
Chael Sonnen and he fights him here in
LA it was a Bellator 170 or something
like that and you know chill makes a
mistake he gets caught in a choke and he
taps and I go to break the hold and you
know Tito strong and he is not wanting
to let go he wants to put him
unconscious and I had you know worked
and thought about hey if someone's not
gonna like it what am I gonna do and if
you go back and you watch you could pull
it up you'll see me taking that thumb
and stuffing it into his freaking
trachea with 280 pounds behind it and he
all of a sudden you know damn John
writes like told you to stop you don't
want to stop I'll make you stop and
these are the things you have to have in
place before it ever happens so when it
happens you're not trying to think of
something you know exactly where you're
gonna go and what you're gonna do and
that's part of refereeing and that's 25
years of doing it but there comes to a
point where just like you said you do
slow down you don't move as much you're
not as quick with your decision-making
and when those things start to happen
it's time to say goodbye oh [ __ ] up oh
[ __ ] yeah is your ego so big that you're
willing to put a fighter safety behind
it it's crazy
I'm happy you're [ __ ] him what's the
name of the podcast name of the podcast
with Josh is weighing in it some sound
Spotify is on you know YouTube all those
things and stuff but we go and normally
it's no more than an hour hopefully what
we talk about relevant fights be at UFC
Bellator people were honest about stuff
sometimes people get pissed off at what
I say and I kind of love
I'm kind of feeling like you now you
know I don't give up [ __ ] and no matter
what you're gonna say oh just someone
who's gonna hate him online yeah we have
a thing called the internet where
everybody has an opinion yep and I had
the weirdest one last night a guy said
to me I went to the wallings and then I
go to Atlanta
and we get to the airport on time
no problem and Atlanta this cloud so
they shut the [ __ ] Airport down so
finally at 6:20 they said we can believe
we would make it to Atlanta at 9:00 and
the dip the shows won't start 7:30
oh so I made an executive decision I
don't listen I know I've been doing this
for 20 [ __ ] years and I know that you
just don't get off a plane at 9:20
they're still walking just the luggage
there's still a bunch of stuff I go and
I mean everybody was like look let him
wait you know and I'm like no cancel the
show we'll come back I don't want them
plus it was raining
yeah that's why the clouds were low I
canceled the show
some people get their refunds back I
redo the date some people say [ __ ] it
just Wolf's wait for the reschedule and
it got so popular I had to have a second
show cool so I had a second show that's
not going my thing I think that goes hey
man I just want to let you know I waited
out there on the rain that day and you
left us flat and I got the refund and
now I come to find that you had a second
show shouldn't you just hook up the fans
for free and I said number one how did
you find out about me I gave me two
podcast a week every week for free
number two the promoter or whatever the
[ __ ] it was I can't blame the promoter
the club the theater they were like [ __ ]
them let them wait out there you show up
when you show up that I can never do you
know and I keep my tickets the cheapest
out of all the comics working I keep
them at like 35 bucks so I'm for the fan
and then he wrote back whatever he felt
but people are never gonna be happy all
that no matter what you're gonna do so
you have to get used to it
I had one row yeah I wrote a book and
the book went out there and I had to do
you know book tour stuff right and so I
did a book tour actually here in LA and
I was living in LA so it was an easy one
but you know I'm there and you know I
don't know you know 50 people were there
and you're signing books and that's you
know answered all the questions and you
know eventually you know it's all done
okay and I leave and it was like 15
minutes before the written time to leave
of 9:00 p.m. I took off in like 8:45 and
some guy I guess came there at 9 o'clock
or right before 9 o'clock and said you
know he wrote out this thing saying you
know I can't believe me I came and you
know he wasn't there it's unprofessional
and stuff like that
and so I actually wrote back and said
hey you know I apologized that if I was
but that we were done you know and I
actually drove to his apartment to give
him a signed book you know and say hey
you know I want you know I do listen and
I understand why you were upset so here
you go and he's like he's standing there
at the door like I can't believe you
know you're here at my apartments like
you know hey I'm just a person and you
can only do what you think is right and
you try to do your best and if you if
you don't understand it then you don't
understand it but yeah it's so funny
people now with you know everyone's
they're all tough guys that's the best
part you know and you know but the ones
that cracks you know my wife is she's
the funniest one because I'm getting all
kinds of people all the time you know
they don't know what I've done
they have no idea who I am you know and
they've seen me referee and we'll say in
the UFC or in Bellator and and so you
know something will come up and I'll say
something and it'll be about we'll say
the rules and they'll say you're just a
referee stay in your lane my wife she
gets like she could she was right I just
let it go who cares you know it doesn't
matter but people have you know their
thing and that's their chance to say
something to you and it cracks me up you
know most the time I tell fighters a
time
don't worry about those because that
person matter in your life you know it
is that the person that you really care
about care about the people that you
know what I listen to Joey Diaz you know
because you know he's a guy that he's
walked that walk he knows and I'll
listen to his opinion because there's
value to me does the guy on Twitter have
value and you're gonna listen and go on
he's got 133 friends not even that 12 12
and you're like you got some [ __ ]
pair of balls now how would a boy adjust
into Nashville you know what my kids are
all two of them are still living out
here okay so you know which is you a
month yeah weird way oh I got a dog
that's about it man I got Jitsu you know
that's that's my living problem it's my
dog but the dog is uh he's awesome a
take him take him out in the cold
weather go on walks just enjoying life
Thank You man for taking the time thank
you all we have my brother it's great
seeing you I'm happy to watch the errand
and end this thing cuz as soon as I saw
that episode yeah I thought about what
you said about Oh Jenna Mike
impulsiveness the [ __ ] yeah it was
just tremendous having you on what's the
name of a podcast again weighing-in
were you then that's it baby you gotta
come on once a week
uh yeah at least once a week once a week
quality you know me I'll do it that's
what I love about don't forget you bad
[ __ ] this weekend I got nothing
but it's Valentine's Day and Tempe I get
that Thursday night the 13th and the
only other day that I got in February is
Treasure Island I think it's February 29
to 28 through the [ __ ] knows go on
Treasure Island calm and see what the
[ __ ] I am the podcast is brought to you
by all right I want to thank Big John I
want to thank the [ __ ]
but most importantly I want to thank you
guys let me read the ads real quick for
you like I said in the beginning of the
[ __ ] show all right when it comes to
supplements is a unit it's a new year
you're trying to make resolutions listen
if I was in a star brand-new I'd start
with some shrimp export just to get the
body going a little bit get those
mushrooms and there get your lungs
expanded a little a protein pile that
they have the chocolate Mexican
chocolate is phenomenal alpha brain is
sensational
you know me dog that [ __ ] keeps you
[ __ ] on fire but loss starts by going
on it calm right now take a look at the
great supplements that they have and you
take it from them putting up a video
today so go to my Instagram it's me
[ __ ] around if you're over 50 you
know three set two swings three sets of
[ __ ] squats and either a French
[ __ ] a Turkish get up three of those
or three [ __ ] cleans and that's all
you need you're over fifty men that's
all you need you don't need too much but
law starts today go to Hahnenkamm real
quick I did not want to speak about this
on the podcast because I didn't want
this to be a downer but I my heart and
the church's family's heart go out they
called me bride and this family but most
importantly the city of Los Angeles
because I've been here for 22 years and
I know what made these the fabric of
this [ __ ] city he was the Willie Mays
of San Francisco he was the Tony Soprano
in New Jersey he was a phenomenal player
and my heart goes out to Kobe Bryant's
family and the most importantly the city
of [ __ ] Los Angeles it's gonna
be a sad week a lot of people gonna be
hurting but hey this is a part of
growing up you could be 41 and worth a
half a billion dollars and you still
can't kind of deal with God so what we
learn from this is that every time you
see your friends on the way out tell
them your love so you have no guilt
later on I love you guys thank you for
listening on a Monday morning have a
great day don't forget get your tickets
early for Tempe Valentine's Day laughing
and sucking that's the name of the
weekend and then in the twenty twenty
ninth I'm a treasure Allen all right you
bad [ __ ]
see you Wednesday morning tip top Magoo
ready to go I love you kick this [ __ ]
melee